not soldiers I have breaking news in the
war for America
we won yes Donald Trump has taken over
the Republican Party faster than ecoli
at my son's graduation party Trump has
the second-highest presidential approval
rating within the Republican Party since
World War two and he has convinced 77
percent of the country that major news
outlets reports fake news which means
we're only 23 percent away from flipping
the New York Times building into a Bubba
Gump shrimp and a new poll shows that
Republicans prefer kim jeong-hoon
to nancy pelosi that's a real poll and
it makes sense at least Kim would
appoint conservative judges but opposers
let's stay humble about this winning
because like george w bush on 9/11 we
didn't do it alone i have to salute
everyone on our side trump
administration all-stars sessions miller
Pruitt's the new guys we've welcomed in
with open arms North Korea Russia the
Philippines Tov countries ones that
don't have time for a free press or
anything else democracies have and who
could forget the brave marchers we stuck
up for and then stuck up for a second
time when asked to clarify if we were
really sticking up for them yes we made
it to the top of the mountain where we
promptly deported our sure and now when
we look in the mirror we will know one
thing for certain the good guys won
we'll be right back
[Applause]
Chuck get back in here Chuck get in get
in get in get in get in get it get it
get it get it get the Liberals gone here
let me check does anyone here know a
podcast promo code for blue apron good
because this is just between us just
between us
Chuck throw up our team again yeah okay
yeah
I think the bad guys won I think
maybe I think maybe we're bad David guys
let's look at our team Putin murders
people kim jeong-hoon
murders people and steven miller
definitely has dreams where he murders
people it's sure none of those people I
just mentioned are Nazis but we also
have Nazis and and oh yeah we are also
the team that puts kids in cages which
doesn't pair well with the alleged child
molester we tried to make a senator this
is bad guys guys I'm starting to
see it now I mean remember when John
McCain tried to stop the Trump train and
then our team mocked him for dying of
brain cancer see we had a choice to side
with either a Republican war hero or
brain cancer and we picked brain cancer
who does that
we do the bad guys that's the team that
we're rooting for guys I mean think
about this let's look at the team we're
fighting against Canada NATO the most
vulnerable groups in America goldstar
parents all pro athletes except for
Dennis Rodman teachers begging for
$30,000 a year every science expert in
every foreign policy expert except for
Dennis Rodman
it feels like we're rooting against
Superman which means we're rooting for
Ben Affleck and that's not good I know
what you're thinking
sure being bad can be kind of fun like
Cobra Kai and Karate Kid and sure
Johnny's the bad guy but he's the fun
kind blond jacked sweeps the leg lightly
bullies someone of a lower socioeconomic
class it's just cool
but when I look at our team more like
Gargamel bat like what the even doing
stop trying to cook those peaceful blue
creatures into soup you goddamn
psychopath
all they want to do is eat mushrooms and
wear their little diapers
I know I know we keep telling ourselves
the ends justify the means
we got strong borders law and order but
maybe how you get those things also
matters to quote a pillow I saw at a TJ
Maxx it's not the destination it's the
journey and if that journey involves
mocking school shooting survivors and
banning Muslims you're the bad guy
yep it was a body pillow sure we all had
fun chanting all this crazy stuff on the
campaign trail but now we're actually
doing it we're like the dog who caught
the car but didn't know what to do so we
panic car and then that car gave birth
to weird dog car hybrid creatures and
instead of questioning any of it we were
like this is what's normal now so gas up
my pug and shut up while we shits all
over your feets how did I get here my
beautiful my beautiful white is this who
we actually want to be have the critics
been right am i hurting America I need a
cold town I need my touchstone my word
blanky Chuck
give me my Golden Rule ah there she is
you only hear from others what you've
already been telling yourself yes sweet
sweet Golden Rule you've helped us out
of so many behinds when the entire
intelligence community agreed that
Russia interfered in our elections we
didn't listen to them we listened to us
and us said investigate Ellery you
handsome devil yeah that sounds
comforting I love that voice
and I can do that and when everyone said
a trade war would take the US economy we
listened to us and I said do it do it do
it
yeah dun dun dun dun and now maple syrup
is going to cost more than sorry I porn
star necklace and that's five
let's go ahead I like my pancakes with
Goldschlager please
golden rule I am at the end of my rope
here I'm looking at Nazis running for
office American institutions being torn
to shreds I want to win I don't want to
feel this way like I'm complicit like
because of our team democracy is on its
last legs
what do I do sweep the leg just like
Cobra Kai sweep the leg no mercy no
mercy no mercy
that giant metaphor was right being the
villain is how we win it's how we stay
in power in spite of all the costs so no
matter how blatantly obvious it is that
we become the worst versions of
ourselves
I guess we'll keep it just between us
the fight continues the fight continues
you you a deep state operative is sent
by George Soros to take away my second
Amendment rights and force-feed me soy
burgers No
well then prove it click and subscribe
and join the opposition now